buon pomeriggio a tutti voi terrestri
noi veniamo dal pianeta atelier
dell'errore
costellazione della neuropsichiatria
infantile
siamo arrivati in questo bellissimo
teatro
accompagnati da una carovana di una
trentina di grandi animali che sono nati
dal nostro dal lavoro nel nostro
laboratorio di arti visive perlé nero
psichiatra infantile
ci ha fatto da guida
questo bestione di due metri per tre che
si chiama il tricheco in innamorato così
ci ha insegnato giovanni nate vi e
giovanni o ragazzino importante nella
storia dell'atelier perché lui 12 anni
fa a domanda precisa
dai giovanni che facciamo un disegno ha
risposto con altrettanta precisione no
ma io non posso disegnare e io non posso
disegnare diverso dal io non so
disegnare con la quale credo la
maggioranza di noi riuscirebbe ad
aggirare la richiesta di un disegno qui
e ora e il tu non sai disegnare subito
ad oltranza
che dentro di lui diventa non posso
disegnare che è un'auto limitazione
un'auto mutilazione della propria
capacità di leggere il mondo
eppure eppure lavorando in atelier
abbiamo scoperto nel tempo che anche
questa sorta di diseducazione artistica
questo abbandono grafico ha dei vantaggi
ai vantaggi rispetto
all'energia del segno
alla forza espressiva e tutto questo è
componente fondamentale di un ambiente
strutturato al servizio della
neuropsichiatra infantile
allo stesso tempo è una ricchezza anche
per il mondo delle arti visive tukur
per questo da quel giorno i 12 anni fa
in atelier segno dopo segno pomeriggio
dopo pomeriggio in atelier abbiamo
sempre disegnato
adesso tocca jub jub ci ha abituati ad
arrivare
in atelier con delle bellissime
ragazzine sul telefonino
ragazzine di cui
si innamorava di cera si fidanzava
diceva e poi lasciava diceva su questa
potenza dell'innamoramento
e del fidanzamento soprattutto i suoi
compagni di gruppo dei lavori hanno
cominciato ad avere dei dubbi lui per
non per difendere la sua onorabilità
un pomeriggio eri venate di elice
beh ma oggi sono stato lasciato io da
una delle mie ragazzina
e quindi oggi non posso disegnare perché
mi sento triste con un canguro
perché sono tutti tristi canguri che
conosce ma no non sono tutti i tristi
però esiste un canguro triste di cuore
perfetta farci conoscere cos'è il
canguro triste del cuore
eccolo cioè consegnato questa creatura
con un segno
scarnificato essenziale
chirurgico verrebbe da dire con facile
autori autoironia visto che a juve porta
in curriculum una dozzina di operazione
alla testa certificate da altrettante
cicatrici però c'è anche il vantaggio di
uk che sa sempre strappati dare infatti
ammicca al suo pubblico conoscere
l'occhio furbo il resto cosa è un corpo
saccà a contenere l'enormità di un cuore
pieno di tutta la tristezza del mondo
una visione anche degli arti superiori
poggia direttamente sulla tristezza del
proprio cuore
i ragazzini ancora juve rilanciano
provano a prendersi cura del nostro
e gli dicono va bè però dai ayub
potreste provare ad invitare una delle
due di queste ragazzine da mcdonald una
volta che ti piace tanto ma no non posso
ci ha già provato ma tutte le volte che
mi trovo davanti a una di queste
ragazzine che a me piace mi sento di
vento una moscatini da che non trova le
parole
allora una mosca timida che ne trovo la
pelle parole già di per sé è una poesia
fatta e finita nella nominazione con
quattro parole scorticate una sorta di a
haiku oltre zoologico di quelli che
succedono spesso i natali nella
nominazione di queste creature
quello che ci lascia è un moscone ed è
mai apparso sulla faccia della terra fin
dalla fondazione del mondo una mosca che
sembra proprio una mosca che non
riuscirà mai a fare la mosca c'è sempre
un taglio autobiografico in tutte le
creature dei ragazzini
adesso che avete
credo intuito come si
guardano e soprattutto come si vedono
animali dell'atelier rilascio in
compagnia del resto della carovana
mentre io vi racconto un po la nostra
storia
io sono un artista visivo e da 12 anni o
questo laboratorio di arti visive per la
neuropsichiatria infantile della usl di
reggio emilia e da tre anni anche per la
neuropsichiatria infantile territoriale
dell'ospedale
dell'ospedale azienda ospedaliera di
bergamo in atelier vivono ragazzini con
le patologie più svariate dai ritardi
più o meno gravi
sindromi disturbi disturbi anche questi
dei più vari dai più semplici e più
complessi sindromi con dei nomi anche
aggraziati
che però lasciano delle conseguenze
abbastanza pesanti sulla vita dei
ragazzi knicks hicks fragile tourette e
anche qualcosa del
famigerato contenitore dell'autismo
anche noi siamo un atelier
fondamentalmente strutturato sulla
narrazione quindi e sul relazione e
quindi non sarebbe esattamente roba da
autistici però coltiviamo 5 se eccezioni
di cui siamo orgogliosissimi del resto
chi si sarebbe mai aspettato che arnulf
rainer uno dei più grandi pittori di 20
fabio proprio invitato due delle nostre
ragazzine
ad inaugurare una mostra internazionale
a monaco di baviera
fra due settimane
siete già tutti invitati
diciamo che c'è un minimo comune
denominatore
che lega tutte queste patologie
e questo minimo comun denominatore
centrato sull'auto stime sulla
socializzazione è anche il motivo per
cui vengono inviate in una teglia di
arti visive a complemento della
neuropsichiatria infantile l'autostima
di questi ragazzini dei miei ragazzini è
pressoché pari a zero
sono quelli che mediamente
hanno percorsi marginali nel didattica
della scuola
però
lavorando sempre con delle iniezioni di
energia da risollevare degli elefanti
con tanto tempo fa tanti percorsi nome
diverso dall'altro
con tante sfide
sfide tutti i giorni sfide soprattutto
per loro stessi fra loro stesso tante
scommesse sogno di loro c'è una piccola
scommessa
il lavoro comincia a dare delle
gratificazioni il lavoro impostato con
una certa serietà e
aumenta la quantità del lavoro con la
soddisfazione aumenta anche la qualità
del lavoro
cominciano le prime mostre
cominciano
primi inviti un po di libri
e loro loro si rianimano non so vi
immaginate uno di questi ragazzini che
mediamente di vacca con l'insegnante di
sostegno a scuola arriva un giorno e
dice professoressa questo è il nostro
libro d'arte vede parla di me c'è il mio
nome
c'è il lavoro che io faccio con i miei
amici questo mio animale di cui solo io
so perché è così e
prove di quel magari l'abbiamo appena
presentato al festival della letteratura
di ivrea è successo poi il festival
libera coscienza eppure è successo
oppure siamo andati al festival
alla fiera d'arte contemporanea di
artverona sa professoressa jean 200
persone ad aspettarci e necessari
divertiti andare sotto il nostro la
nostra creatura vedere la faccia di
quegli sconosciuti che hanno pagato 5
euro per venire a vedere il nostro
lavoro
è così questo è questo tipo di
esperienza personale questa
gratificazione
autentica è un po il bene durevole che
deposita lavoro in atelier nella
profondità di questi ragazzini un bene
durevole che al di là di tutto mai
nessuno al mondo potrà loro portare via
per quanto riguarda la socializzazione è
ancora più semplice di come scusate ma
voi come fate già a conoscervi prima di
arrivare nate libera facile siamo quelli
dell'insegnante di sostegno oppure siamo
quelli che alle feste di compleanno non
vengono invitati a mano facilissima ma
fin qui uno lo può intuire
cristo le problematicità la cosa che
invece mi ha sempre sorpreso il fatto
che questa marginalità aggancia spesso
le spalle famiglie e quindi c'è una
deriva sociale anche delle famiglie dei
ragazzini che hanno queste problematiche
e questo ci ha spinto quattro anni fa a
fondare un associazione che si chiama
fratelli dell'errore onlus che ha il
compito di coinvolgere i genitori in
questo lavoro che evidentemente non
possono venire da te li non ha senso non
possono aiutarci a far conoscere invece
il lavoro dei loro figli in atelier
adesso vorrei raccontarvi
perché noi ci chiamiamo tesi dell'errore
e perché siamo così orgogliosi di questo
nome allora il primo motivo è che dire
dal fatto che il primo e più grande
errore in atelier sono stato io nel
senso che non è un lavoro che la scelta
adesso dopo 12 anni posto con una certa
serenità dire che forse questo lavoro mi
ha scelto sono stato scelto dalla teglia
cosa per quello che è venuto anche
abbastanza bene
e
però io ho sofferto i primi il primo
anno in atelier mi sentivo ho provato il
senso di inadeguatezza l'essere inadatti
rispetto alla complessità che non
conosce la complessità di questi
ragazzini e soprattutto dal punto di
vista delle arti visive non aveva ancora
intuito la profondità e la ricchezza di
un'immaginaria perché questo immaginario
loro speciale lo vedete sta sotto una
stratificazione di sconfitte che
difficile da perforare da tre da
trivellare questo è il problema
lasciare emergere alla luce del sole
questa ricchezza
ci aiutato nel tempo la remora razzista
per esempio c'è
l'affiorare di creature
credo
strabilianti non tanto per l'impatto
grafico ma per le storie per le storiche
custodiscono
e poi
se io ho passato mi sono sentito un
errore per un pomeriggio alla settimana
e ascoltando loro poi capito che in
effetti loro si sentono poi un errore
per sette giorni alla settimana quattro
settimane al mese
dodici mesi l'anno e questa
consapevolezza mi ha aiutato a fare un
salto qualitativo sul mio sguardo
interiore che è stato quello di
abbandonare per un po
la norma lo edita nel mia squadra e fare
un salto di là dove si stava
dischiudendo questo mondo il mondo
dell'atelier dove impari per esempio che
il contrario di normale è speciale
il contrario di guardare e vedere
il controllo di sentire di ascoltare e
sentire
questi sono stati i primi due motivi per
cui noi siamo latte di dell'errore il
terzo invece più metodologico la nostra
non è una scuola di disegno segnano
anche accademici per definizione
sperimentiamo molto quello sì e quindi
a me non interessa che lo diventino dei
disegnatori ma che prendono confidenza
sulla possibilità di diventare
originali e originanti creatori di
creature questo vuol dire che di fronte
al foglio che raccoglie l'informe dei
primi segni fallimentari non ti arrendi
come sarebbe facile ma ti sforzi di
guardare e riguardare dove tutti
guardano e pochi vedono che mi sembra un
ottimo esercizio poetico e allora partì
da una zebra in che inciampa e diventa
una formica si rialza per diventare un
drago e poi magari finalmente entra nell
inconscio
uno di questi animali
11 al mondo
come unici al mondo siamo tutti noi a
cominciare da loro
detto questo
pensandoci bene
sono tutti noi non avessimo ereditato un
dna capace non solo di generare errori e
affrontarle disco di superarli
anche noi questa sera saremmo più o meno
555 batteri ben allineati e questo è il
terzo motivo per quindi sono molto
orgoglioso di essere da tagliare
l'errore adesso vorrei
spero che sia di buon auspicio parlarvi
del progetto fondamentale di quest'anno
noi o cinque ragazzini che passano dalla
neuropsichiatra infantile al di capa
adulto
purtroppo landy capo adulto e mediamente
terapia occupazionale
esattamente l'opposto di quello che noi
facciamo in atelier problema è che se tu
apri la testa una persona non puoi
pensare che dopo questa la richiude a
koman e quindi c'è un disadattamento
notevole nel passaggio con nk adulto
quello che noi vogliamo fare costruire
un gruppo di lavoro di formazione lavoro
un'alta scuola di arti visive piacerebbe
diventasse per bambini che vengono dalla
neuropsichiatria infantile e che si
autofinanzi con operazioni tipo queste
installazioni opere urbane
e anche
grafica editoria
se questa cosa ci riesce
ecco allora forse riusciamo a realizzare
una piccola grande utopia sociale che è
la quadratura del cerchio del progetto
sarebbe forse speriamo cioè quello di
trasformare una criticità una
problematicità sociale in ricchezza
una ricchezza sociale che è bellezza
bellezza un termine purtroppo che è
stato esautorato da un sacco di
declinazione certamente non è la
bellezza
la bellezza
autoreferenziale e di doni stica del è
bello ciò che mi piace no non è niente
di tutto questo non è neanche la
bellezza
diciamo in qualche modo cosmetica con
cui ci tedia il mondo della pubblicità è
una bellezza che si rifà a un nucleo ben
più antico la bellezza come mediatore
come me taxi come mediazione verso il
bene dell'uomo un bene da ricercare da
condividere adesso facciamo un passo
indietro rispetto agli avanzamenti
torniamo a due secoli fa la bellezza
definita in maniera ancora perfetta nel
nostro caro principe di miss chi ne
l'idiota di dostoevskij la bellezza che
salverà il mondo
noi a questa cosa andate lì e ci
crediamo ancora grazie a tutti grazie